it's been quite a long goal journey and
there you summed it up pretty well
though you know working in the factories
sleeping in my car and of course as you
mentioned losing an eye along the way
and yeah i never thought it would come
to this but uh here we are it's almost
midnight here in los angeles but i'm uh
i just got out of bed actually i set my
alarm it's uh it sounds very very rock
and roll but uh i'm old these days i got
three kids i went to bed i set my alarm
and it's a pleasure to talk to you well
you look fantastic i wish i looked like
that when i just woken up
talk to me about how you lost your eye
well listen you know i mean the sport i
take part in it's uh you know it's a
beautiful sport but it's also very
vicious and of course it's mixed martial
arts so you know you can punch kick knee
and elbow and unfortunately i got kicked
in the head of a guy down in brazil
called vito belfort who uh was on every
performance enhancing drug under the sun
and sadly that caused my retina to
detach i got it fixed it redetached so
on and so forth six surgeries later and
sadly yeah you know i've got one eye but
still in the land of the blind the
one-eyed man is king that's what they
say but how challenging does it make you
fighting when you've only got one eye
because it must be such a big
difference that you have to uh get used
to
yeah just a little bit you know people
always say to me how did you fight with
one eye and i always say with great
difficulty you know obviously the depth
perception is way off in fact it's
non-existent so it was very very
difficult but uh fortunately i have some
very patient coaches and uh you know we
managed to get the job done the thing
was the hardest part was keeping it
secret this whole time because obviously
you know uh getting licensed with one
eye isn't very very easy so uh i'd sell
a few porcupies along the way but still
i'm retired now so now i can start
telling the truth
and now you can tell some stories on
tour tell us about that
yeah that's right yeah so i did a
one-man show a couple of years ago in
toronto and uh if you've ever seen the
mike tyson one-man show on disputed
truth i guess it's something like that
however i didn't squander 400 million
dollars or go to prison for rape so uh
it's not too similar i guess in that
regard but still yeah so i did it in
toronto and uh everyone really enjoyed
it it was a real good laugh and then
some promoters that i got talking to you
know they
they came to me with an offer and i'm
doing a mini tour throughout the uk and
the support was so great that's actually
i'm coming back next year we're doing uh
way more dates in england we're doing
mainland europe we're doing australia
new zealand so where it's kind of taking
on a life of its own but i'm very
excited fortunately the ufc has a really
passionate fan base in the uk and ticket
sales have been tremendous there is some
still available though so if anyone's
doing anything next week in birmingham
london manchester or glasgow get
yourself to my ticket dot com or you can
come along and then enjoy the fun that's
a big plug uh michael
why why are you in l.a why are you not
here
uh well well the weather believe it or
not
i do miss the rain but said no my wife's
australian and uh the ufc predominantly
you know it's an american sport and i
had the work visa and my wife
you know she wasn't too keen on the
reign so uh we came out here just to do
some training camps but we've got three
children and uh one's twenty one's
nineteen and one's eleven and now we've
been here for ten years uh it's kind of
home for them and i wanna come back to
england all the time but my wife would
never dream of leaving the kids and uh
yeah she doesn't want to go back to the
rain so i miss it dearly but
it is what it is